[Music]
[Music]
no so this is funny i went to um
i went to emo night
because our friend was like djing yeah i
don't know i don't know i don't know how
like you know we ended up there okay
and
so my friend's set was from 11 30 to
or 11 to 11 30 11 to 11 20 and then it
was like he was showing me the set list
on his phone or like the list of artists
right and then it was like someone else
from 11 uh 40 to 12 10. and then it said
mgk
12 10 to 12 40. i was like
okay
what is a joke right he's like no he's
really coming i was like there's no
[ __ ] way
he's gonna show up at 12 10 to do a 30
minutes
little like i kid you not 1209 his voice
comes on the mic i'm like no way and i
go and i'm probably standing this far
from him
and he's standing on the stage so it's
like literally we're just like
and i was i got kind of scared for a
second i was like i don't think i should
be in
view of this guy
our clips making fun of him went pretty
[ __ ] viral
what if he just locks eye contact with
me in the middle of his set and it's
like yo what the [ __ ] that made fun of
us on on tick tock is here you know yeah
and then you're like yeah i did
better be a good show
yeah but it's emo night everyone's on
his side they're not on my side
yeah you know what i mean
the price of being a comedian
yeah i guess but i just i don't know for
some reason i got
kind of worried
no you should have flipped them off yeah
yeah
it's pretty funny too megan fox was just
like standing in the crowd like
just filming him
and it was it was it was an interesting
crowd
very sweaty
yeah you know
and it was uh i just she was like pretty
out of place yeah
yeah people were just dancing for like
and moshing
it was like four hours of that up until
the point where he came on and they both
just like came in from their like
helicopter or however the [ __ ] they got
there yeah
just pristine condition right she's
wearing this beanie that's just like
propped on her head like this and she's
just like
filming him and everyone's like just
surrounding them on stage yeah sweating
beer
you know smelly
smelly
smoothie yeah
what
it was lit
no it was it wasn't fun until i got that
street dog
yeah
you shared one with mgk
yeah he's like i heard what the [ __ ] you
said dude yeah
if i wasn't eating this street dog right
now i'd whup your ass
damn that seems like it was fun no it
actually was fun i had a good time i
remember i went to one of the first
emo nights ever
and now it's like a tour they tour
they're in like every single city it's
like a franchise
and uh
yeah it's just interesting they were
kind of ahead of the curve they kind of
like definitely nailed it yeah just by a
stroke of luck
you know like let's let's do this it's
cool and the industry was like oh yeah
we're we're endorsing this hard
you